ja hallo aus frankfurt das hat
eigentlich direkt zu beginn des
angekündigten demo zuges angefangen
der konnte überhaupt nicht los ziehen
weil sich die antifa in der straße
positioniert hatte
so stehen die herdecker demo gehen
sollte dh der demozug der querdenker weg
konnte überhaupt nicht erst los ziehen
bis da geräumt wurde die antifa die war
gut organisiert die leute haben sich
immer wieder zerstreut und haben sich in
den gassen auch als route geändert wurde
immer wieder gesammelt und haben dann da
die route erneut blockiert dagegen ist
dann die polizei sehr konsequent
vorgegangen und ist mit dem wasserwerfer
angerückt und hat dann so die antifa
sich ja da wieder aufgelöst die blockade
so dass die querdenker demo dann
weitergehen konnte bis eigentlich zu
dieser geplanten kundgebung die dann in
der stadtmitte stattfinden sollte bis
man aber dann da an kam war es dann
schon sehr später nachmittag und da
wurde dann alles aufgelöst
auch mit einem wasserwerfer genau ich
wollte fragen vor kurzem hat die polizei
ihre wasserwerfer auch gegen die
querdenker eingesetzt kannst du uns dazu
noch mal sagen was wir wissen ja die
polizei hat die braker mehrmals
aufgefordert den platz zu räumen weil
sich den tag über während des umzuges
auch nicht an die strengen auflagen
gehalten wurde
die auflagen waren dass sie schweren des
zuges an die abstände gehalten wird das
mosten getragen werden es trügen aber
sehr viele keine masken
es wurde auch zu beginn kontrolliert
dass diejenigen die tatsächlich keine
masken trugen auch ein attest vorweisen
können
das kann aber gar nicht sagen dass so
viele menschen wie jetzt keine maske
getragen haben einen alten art es dafür
hatten
das heißt da wurde dann einmal gesagt so
jetzt war ich es das wird jetzt
aufgelöst ihr habt jetzt einen kurzen
zeitraum um diesen platz zu verlassen
ein hartnäckiger harter kern hat das
nicht getan dann kam auf der
wasserwerfer und hat da einmal rein
geduscht und dann ging das dann auch
recht schnell dass dann die demo dann da
vorbei war
das war natürlich stand große
katerstimmung bei den querdenkern weil
die hatten
bühnen aufgebaut wollten jedoch noch
kundgebung machen das war bis 17 uhr 30
angesetzt und um 16 uhr 20 war dann aber
schluss das heißt die bauen hier hinter
mir eigentlich nur noch ihre bühnen ab
die überhaupt nicht zum einsatz kamen
und lisa jetzt haben wir jetzt bist du
wieder da wir haben gerade werden du
gesprochen hast bilder gesehen von den
wasserwerfern das ist also eine
strategie gewesen der polizei was war
die weitere strategie und wie bewertest
du das ganze vor ort jetzt ist es ja
vorbei also die strategie der polizei
war ja aufgrund von vorneherein dass die
demo auf einen kleinen möglichst kleinen
raum begrenzt wird das heißt es wurde
nur eine kurze strecke erlaubt aber
genau die ist ja eigentlich hier zum
verhängnis geworden
das führte dann durch diese engen gassen
im bereich hauptbahnhof und das hat dazu
geführt meiner einschätzung nach das
auch eben die gegendemo der antifa
eigentlich so erfolgreich war weil die
kunden immer wieder einfach direkt um
die nächste ecke laufen
sobald dann der wasserwerfer kam sobald
die dann die blockade darauf gelöst
bekommen sind gegen die nächste ecke
gelaufen und haben sich stark
positioniert und zack sind sie dann
wieder aneinandergeraten also was heißt
aneinandergeraten
in dem sinne die polizei stand natürlich
dazwischen aber das war dann wieder so
eine situation wo man sich gegenüber
stand einerseits die querlenker
dazwischen polizei und dann auf der
anderen seite die antifa und dann stoppt
ihr das ganze wieder in diesem gassen
und es kam zu eher unschönen situationen
dann doch mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bet schau dir das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren